hey where have you been oh you were  supposed to be here working i lost track  of time this is the real world sometimes  you just gotta let your dreams go  i just scribble in my notebook i'm a  stock boy that's it you are a legit  designer  let me add them  dude i love it  [Music]  oh  i want to lick them  i'm kira oh hold up  kyra king aka sneaker royalty  boom the king's charity gala yeah design  some sick kicks show off your talent at  the most exclusive sneaker event of the  year that could happen this is your shot  come on get up  you've got sneakers to make  [Music]  it's you did you design these yeah  you're the guy  that everybody's been talking about  tonight this is  [Music]  i've been this destiny i was three years  old i'm going for my goals to the stars  than my kids  [Music]  you